amongst this group of very successful
people it was very clear that Jimmy is
an outlier he's an outlier because of
his mindset because of his ambition
because of his level of of obsession
because of his work ethic because of his
absolute disregard for social norms so
let me just tell you some things that
stood
[Music]
out what's up Sam uh I'm back I'm back
from Camp MFM you Camp is it even called
Camp MFM if only one of us went I don't
know we have to debate that but I'm back
I have so much good stuff to share I
have this is it's a crazy event honestly
it's kind of a batshit Crazy Event I'll
give it batshit crazy it is so
interesting what happened here I have so
many notes I'm going to share with you
but first I saw something completely
unrelated that I got to tell you about
so by the way before we even get to all
of that we have to explain that you
hosted this big event now you're going
to tell me some amazing thing that you
just saw we do all of this for free and
all we are ask asking for our dear
viewer here if you're on YouTube hit
that subscribe button for us that's all
we ask for and people say that all the
time but you want to know what Sean what
I want to make sure that our listeners
our viewers know it takes them literally
a second but it means so much to us and
actually changes Our Lives if everyone
does it so hopefully people will see the
dedication that we have in this content
and pay us back by just giving us a
subscribe so that's all I want to say
change life just change a life today
with one simple tap um all right so
before I tell you all about Camp FM I
got to tell you about this amazing Evil
Genius affiliate marketing play that I
saw uh somebody share on Twitter so I
don't know if you saw this it involves
23 and me so okay so basically this guy
points us out he goes check this out
this is the most Evil Genius thing I've
ever seen and he points out this tweet
that um a user her name is Stella posted
and she says hey my friend Elizabeth is
looking for an unvaxxed sperm
donor Sam you're halfway there um she
said I'm looking for somebody who's
blue-eyed
white which
half like I'm I'm vaccinated but I now
you to convince me to give my sperm
or you're half eligible uh all right so
blue-eyed white 511 or taller blah blah
blah so it has this set of requirements
big go
yeah big go but then uh there's there's
some things in here that are like a
little bit interesting makes you raise
one eyebrow so first one she says
follows a healthy meat focused diet
specific but okay second no Jewish or
African ancestry slightly racist but
okay then it says must be natural
insemination she will not do IVF DM me
okay so she doesn't want to do the
normal sperm donation process wants
natural insemination which means 10
white guy who's unvaxxed so basically
anyone who lives in Missouri she wants
to have sex
with got it so okay you see that first
thing then she tweets again says hey
that last tweet got so many so much
inbound I just want to add some detail
um so she retweets it again reiterates
the criteria but then she adds some
photos of the girl too she says as you
could see she is beautiful pure blooded
European okay code word uh intelligent
has a childbearing body which I've
always dreamed of having myself and uh
your offing will be raised extremely
well and they post a bunch of pictures
of her and it's like this kind of hot
model looking girl so this guy points
out he's like this tweet got like almost
three million views and if you do it if
you DM the person then they send you a
link and they're like hey cool you're
interested awesome um you know she would
love to have you know naturally
conceived with you um Random 5 foot1
white guy who's unvaxxed um you just got
to make sure you have the you satisfy
all the criteria take this 23 and me and
submit your results and then that'll say
that you're eligible but it's like an
affiliate code for 23 and me this girl's
so probably this I say this girl there's
probably no girl what it actually is is
this fat guy in his basement is tricking
tons of guys who are like maybe I'll
impregnate this this hot European model
um I just got to take this 23 and me and
basically even if you get paid the the
normal 23 and me like referral bonus is
20 bucks per person who does it so if
you just do the math on this funnel
three million people see this tweet
let's say that one tenth of
1% are gonna actually go do
this that's 3,000 people that went and
did this at minimum that's 60k in
Revenue off this tweet of affiliate
Revenue
isn't this crazy that next week 23 of me
is sitting down they're like at their
marketing uh they're in their marketing
meeting and they're like all right we
have to like let's do some let's look at
the data and see who our Target
demographic is wow like I apparently
this marketing company just told us they
did some research our new users love
Jorts should we like should we have a
bunch of white guys named Todd who wear
like jean shorts in our commercials like
like that's is that our new Target
demographic they just like everything
skew now where they're just like all
this one type of person totally totally
they're like oh I guess Twitter's our
best Channel and Stella appears to be
our best retailer who is Stella should
we be advertising on Twitch is this evil
or is it Evil Genius because it's a fine
line between evil and Evil Genius I I
think it's Evil Genius so let's go on to
the next part Camp MFM all right so
let's start with the following was it
good was it great was it
lifechanging I'm going to go with
lifechanging I'm going to go with life
changing that's how it was everyone I
spoke with who went it ranged between
the worst was great the highest was
life-changing so you had a good that's a
good high NPS so let me just explain
what we did so we basically took 20
people to um to Greenville North
Carolina which is middle of nowhere um
we basically stayed at Mr BEAST's house
uh there so last year we we did this
thing once and we realized oh this is
really cool if we bring a bunch of
interesting people that we know in the
business world and then a few
entertainers and some people that Mr
Beast knows in his world this can become
a very interesting event we did it again
this year we had 20 people and I got
some highlights I got some low lights
but where do you want to start how
should I how should I do
this I can find this client info have
you heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow
better what what I actually wanted to
ask you about was uh the evolution of
Jimmy aka Mr Beast because my perception
of him last year so I went and hung out
I went to Lan last year I couldn't go
this year but last year how old is he
was he 24 last year went 25 now okay so
he's super young and and and so here's
my perception of him when I met him last
year he had he clearly had this factor
of like I hadn't met anyone like him but
when we talk about like a Steve Jobs or
or a and Elon Musk these conquerors like
he had that it Factor it was very clear
that this guy was crazy focused and he
was insane and mostly all the right ways
but he still had some aspects of a
normal 24y old um he felt a little
impatient about certain things he felt
like uh he was still trying to like he
had he had great conversations but then
there's other times where it's like oh
you're just a normal 24y old where you
uh maybe are are you said something rude
or something like that and then this
year I heard from someone who went from
the year before they go dude Jimmy has
evolved so much he's he's still only 25
but which is insane he's only 25 but he
now has like is morphing into this
proper Visionary where I believe that
he's going to take over the world was
that true a lot of that is true uh you
could see the evolution which is kind of
crazy so he um so for people who don't
know Jimmy is basically one of
the most famous people on planet Earth
it's kind of like bizarre when you look
at the numbers like he is the biggest
Creator on the biggest app in the world
he's he's the number one most followed
Creator on YouTube he's almost the
number one channel on YouTube there's
only like one channel that's bigger
which is like this Indian music channel
um he's the fastest growing he's the
biggest he's the biggest on YouTube he's
the biggest on Tik Tok so the two
biggest entertainment apps in the world
YouTube and Tik Tok he's the basically
the number one Creator on both weren't
the stats like one out of five what was
it was it uh maybe like one out of 10
people on Earth see his videos once a
month or something like some stupid stat
like that dude you can look at this a
100 ways and it's insane it's like more
people watch his content than watch the
Super Bowl every month it's like okay
well what are we doing here what is this
how what is this mean I think like his
average video gets 80 million views
unique it's hard to even like fathom
that and then you go outside with him
and you know wherever you
are it's like a Michael Jackson level of
Fame right so was it really I mean we
didn't go anywhere last year but you
guys like basically didn't go anywhere
this year but you can still see it it
still happens um so so kind of insane so
that's the first thing it's just hard to
even wrap your head around that level of
of Fame and success at this age he's
running a billion dollar company so he's
his his company is worth well over a
billion dollars which is the combination
of his channel is he the running it yeah
it's him it's his the whole ship is him
right like but does he have a CEO or is
he also the CEO he has like a CEO but
like the CEO reports to him he's the
owner right so like the owner is number
one um okay so he's got basically what
what changed from last year let's start
with that uh first the guy lost 30
pounds so after last year's Camp uh he
watched the video of himself playing
basketball was like oh my got up so slow
and out of shape F this and you could
see that like you know the type of
person who can become the number one
Creator on YouTube You Know by obsessing
and focusing for 10 years guess what
that guy can transform his body in a
year too right so he's like on an
extreme like bodybuilder workout uh
program he's got like his bodybuilder
meals he's got his trainer who follows
him around and they built a gym right
outside of his Studio that we went and
hung out in it's like this is where he
works out he's big he's like I only have
three goals this year grow the channel
get big and sell chocolate those are the
three things he's doing and like that's
another interesting thing last year when
we talked to him I don't know you didn't
go to his Studio last year but we did
and um he had like 10 things he was
doing it was like oh I want to you know
do this mobile gaming thing and then I'm
doing this over here I'm doing this this
and uh because why not he could do any
of those things right like you and me
find it hard to say no
opportunities texted Ben times more Ben
was so every night me and Ben so Ben
Levy he is my business partner he
organize the whole event but during the
event we're basically not talking
because we're just working different
parts of the room and you know me and
Ben talked 247 anyway so we don't need
to talk at this event but at the end of
the night he would text me like yo like
all right brain dump like we would just
text random words we don't even explain
them to each other like we'll talk about
this later here's some takeaways here's
some insights here's some learnings
here's some ways we could help somebody
in this room like whatever and one of
the things I text him I go it's
embarrassing man
Jimmy has one literally at least 1,000
times more opportunities than us like
this podcast creates a lot of
opportunities and you know where we are
in the tech world to create some
opportunities but he literally has at
least a thousand X more
opportunities and he does less he says
yes to less stuff than we did we have
like we're doing four things he's doing
two and like that's insane like that's
that just shows like how poorly we are
are are are staying focused and
committed to what actually matters and
being smart about say yes and no to
things I said if this guy could say no
to literally a thousand or maybe 10,000
better opportunities than what we're
saying no to like we that's something to
learn from so okay what changed uh he
lost a bunch of weight his channel has
basically like doubled in the last year
that we we talked to him he's like added
like I don't know 100 million more
subscribers uh his chocolate business
has taken off so I really underestimated
this chocolate business Feasta bles when
I had a a chance to invest in this thing
like at the earlier rounds and I was
like chocolate company like that's I
don't know why why chocolate like uh I
get it your audience is young but like
chocolate's kind of like low priced it's
like uh you know yeah I mean how often
do people how often do people Reby this
thing like shouldn't he be building like
you know a mobile game or something like
that that's kind of what I was thinking
and last year when we were with them I
think the results were like it's okay or
it's it it might it might be okay like
it was kind of like number three he was
like oh I got Beast Burger it's say
Burger chain virtual restaurant that's
doing I think it was doing like 100
million gross or something at the time
they've since shut that down um and then
or or he like doesn't work on that
anymore they had like a couple of things
in the pipe they had this like
translation service thing for like
YouTubers whatever they had all this
stuff chocolate was like number three
maybe last year and now it's like every
day I wake up and think how do I sell
more chocolate right it's like that
level of like hyper Obsession and
you know going to do hundreds of
millions in chocolate sales this year
with a clear path to how this could
become like he's like basically he like
there's five chocolate companies that
matter they're valued in the billions up
to you know $30 billion doar uh we are
eating share like crazy um you know
these guys can't touch us when it comes
to marketing and so you know we are just
blowing through the like retail doors
basically it's like yeah like get into
Walmart Walmart is the main thing and
guess what can drive more people to
Walmart than these guys can and so he
has just like really blown that business
up which is pretty impressive you know
now it's pretty obvious that that's
going to be a a billion dollar plus
business I would bet that he's gonna
sell that chocolate brand
for6 billion doll that's my guess I
think that's what's gonna I think if we
fast forward the news three years from
now uh you know Mr Beast sells the
majority stake or in the chocolate
business for at a $6 billion do
valuation that's insane and what about
his mindset um so you said he focused
more um what else changed well so Joe
Rogan has this thing he says about David
Goggins where he goes he's uncommon
amongst uncommon men so this room was
really interesting because I don't know
the average Network you know even take
out Joe who's like you know worth like
seven to 10 billion dollars or something
you know when we were doing the intros I
was like you know between me and Joe
we're worth almost 10 billion dollar
it's just all Joe
the so so basically even if you take him
out of it you know this is a room of
very very successful people average
probably like I don't know hundred
million dollars net worth or something
like that it amongst this group of very
successful people it was very clear that
Jimmy is an outlier he's an outlier
because of his mindset because of his
ambition because of his level of of
obsession because of his work ethic
because of his absolute disregard for
social norms so let me just tell you
some things that stood out so basically
he's he was very humble he was like you
know he's like I he's like I've made
every mistake you can make trying to run
this business he's like I've hired and
fired like six CEOs I thought we hire
the Disney guy surely he'll know things
no he doesn't know [__] about YouTube
that's not going to work uh we hire this
person over here and then they build the
whole thing out and I realized oh my God
they buildt this WR we got to get rid of
all that he's like so I've made all
these mistakes he's like so I want to
learn from you guys because i' I'm only
25 I've only been doing this for a
couple years now you guys might have
been doing this for 20 more years than
me right like there people in the room
were 50 years old right so it's like
it's a different um different like level
of experience he's like he's like I'm
just making things up I'm sitting here
in North Carolina just making things up
I don't even have access to people like
you on most days to even ask questions
so he'd be like I'll tell you some
examples so he's like uh we were like so
what worked for you how have you scaled
this thing up he goes oh I just create
clones and we were like what he's like
yeah I just wanted to clone myself
because I was like God I know I could do
this but I don't have the time so I need
to clone somebody he's like like what do
you mean what do you do he's like so I
literally have somebody essentially move
in with me and I just duct tap them duct
tape them to my hip he's like you're G
to follow me everywhere to everything
and for this first six months all you're
G to do is just Shadow me and just learn
exactly how I think and what I want and
what I do and why I do it and then in
six months you start getting your you
start doing those things and he's like I
basically now cloned myself several
times and now I have and then they clone
themselves he's like that's what we do
and we're like so you literally have the
guy live with you he's like yeah what
that it would be better than if he
didn't right we're like yeah but like
what about his like family and stuff
he's like yeah I mean I just you you
want to do this or
not so like like one of the guys one of
the guys who's like his right-hand man
now last year when we went he was a guy
just like uh you know he does these
challenges like live in this circle for
100 days and you get like half a million
dollars this was the guy living in the
circle he was just like a random
contestant but he had a back ground in
video production and he had some
experience and so they actually
recruited him after that experiment to
work with him now he's like his
right-hand man does everything with him
he's with him 247 I was like dude you
got like kids this is like a Saturday
are you supposed to be working he's like
yeah I work every day I work all day
every day and he's like I made a deal
with my family I was like look I'm
coming out here it's a Once in
a-lifetime experience you're not going
to see me for like the next nine months
hopefully after nine months I will have
like set up a system where I'll be back
you know a little bit more but like this
is an this is an adventure and I want to
go on it this is like the Pinnacle of my
career it's a once at a lifetime
opportunity to work with this guy on
this type of stuff so I'm going to go
all in and this Allin mentality was just
so P pervasive I'll give you another
simple example the guy who's currently
his assistant we were like how'd you get
the job as assistant and he's like oh um
we're like did you interview for this
how did he like pick you he's like no I
an interview he's like they uh really
wanted to play this board game but you
know Amazon Prime was going to take two
days and so one of his guys hit me up
because he knew I had the game and he's
like fly here right now and uh we want
this game now we want to play now we
don't want to wait two days for Amazon
Prime we want to play this game tonight
he's like so I just got on a flight and
I came and I handed them the board game
and they were like cool if you're
willing to do that you can like you can
make it here H do you want do you want a
job you're extreme enough and he's like
he's describ so I was asking this guy I
was like how do you filter for this cuz
they were they were trying to pick up
like how do we keep this culture as we
scale of people who are just all in and
he's like uh he's like now when I
interview people we do like these
psychographic like tests to get figure
out your personality profile but he's
like then I'm going to talk to you he's
like I'm gonna spend an hour convincing
you how hard this is going to be and how
much you're going to have to sacrifice
to be here and I can just see in that do
they Flinch do they start asking me
about vacation
policies or do they get excited about
like kind of like going on this Mission
like this Mission to Mars and our of
their version of the mission of Mars I
thought that was fascinating that he's
basically breeding this insane work
culture the team has leveled up so much
the quality of people he has around him
from last year to this year has leveled
up so much and he just breaks all the
social norms like just being like yeah
uh he's like one guy he's like I talked
to his main like one of his like main
content guys is like editor thumbnail
guy like this guy's job title is like
master of thumbnails basically he just
does thumbnails and I was like how did
this work he's like well I had my own
channel that was doing well I was how do
you convince you to do this he's like
well his channel was taken off he's like
we were always talking about like
strategies and ideas every day and like
our little Mastermind and we would just
sit in Discord all day and talk about
what like what's working what's not
studying the platform and he's like I
just knew this guy's like hyper obsessed
he's gonna make it and he offered me the
he's like first I started helping him
and he wasn't paying me or whatever I
was just helping him out whenever I
could he's like then he told me like hey
I need uh you know I need a thumbnail
for this like tonight he's like oh dude
sorry I'm at a wedding and like by the
way I don't work for you so you know
it's not going to work he's like so he
wired me 10 grand and he's like uh he's
like can you make the thumbnail please
he's like so I told my girlfriend he's
like I left the wedding and I made the
thumbnail and I've never looked back
since and since my role has grown and
you know he's made it all worth my while
to be here to shut down my own channel
to go all in and I just thought it was
fascinating the level of
like like disregard for like convention
partly because he doesn't know it and
partly because he's like well we need
this so what's the best way like can't
we just theoretically couldn't we just
find a guy with the game and tell him to
book a flight and he'll be here in a few
hours cool we're not limited by Amazon
shipping like 99 people out of a 100
would not try to bypass Amazon's fastest
shipping as like the way to get
something I remember um years ago 10
plus years ago my wife went to Facebook
and she was um telling her father about
working at Facebook and I think my wife
worked there starting when there was 6
or 9,000 people I forget and uh my
father-in-law was like why do you need
9,000 people to run a website like why
do you need 9,000 people for like a web
page what do you what all those people
do and that's what I I someone had said
that Jimmy has uh Mr Beast has um uh
hundreds of employees working for him
and at first I was like how do you need
hundreds of employees and then I had to
re I had to rethink it I'm like well no
he's actually he's a movie Studio it
just instead of theaters it's on it's on
your phone or on your TV I was like this
guy's he's just built like the new the
new Paramount or whatever the studios
are the Warner Brothers and that's
exactly what he's doing and it's crazy
fascinating because you know I did this
a little bit with newsletters but not
with nearly that intensity where it was
like let's just take a small thing or
something people think is small and try
to blow it up and at the time it was
email people thought it was uh just like
a something you disregard I'm like no we
can get like 5 million subscribers and
turned into a business and of course it
was only a fraction of what he did but
that's basically what he has done with
YouTube but at a with a much better
result where he's like what's this one
this one small thing that people are
dismissing and he's built a whole studio
around it it's pretty amazing and the
other thing you know if you talk to him
he's like
uh he's like it's impossible to do what
I'm doing better than me he's like
because I'm GNA
spend you know 10 times more than anyone
I use every waking hour of my day to
think about this I hire all the best
people in the world I reinvest all of my
profits back into this and I'm gonna do
this and he's like and I think in
decades not not years so how could you
beat that and if you just abstract this
away like forget about the fact that
he's doing that for YouTube channels
like there's something to be inspired by
and learn from that from that right like
if you are willing to work in thinking
decades not years work every hour every
every thought in your brain is consumed
by how do I do this better um you
reinvest all your money and say I will
spend as much as I can to make the best
product possible to get this into as
many people's hands as possible like can
you lose like what is there to fear what
how could you possibly lose with that
equation and I think that that is just
like a very fascinating uh mindset to
see in practice a lot of people could
say that [__] very few people can
actually do it and I know that he says
he invests everything and and we had
Reed on the Pod and he had kind of
insinuated that like sometimes what they
do is it's a mess like because they move
so fast like we just miss some stuff but
that's okay do you think that Jimmy is
Cash poor then like is he just like
everything is tied up into his business
I don't know I don't want to speculate
too much on that but uh I think you know
the reality is he ra he he's a he is a
venture back startup he raised venture
capital and he is doing what you know um
what an Airbnb did or what a Facebook
did was like I'm gonna lose a ton of
money now every year building up all of
this market share so that then I can
make back you know I could become a 10
billion or hundred billion dollar
company that's literally what he's doing
he raised like 50 million plus and
invest all of that into content to G
build this enormous following of being
the most followed Creator on Tik Tok and
YouTube and you know hundreds of
millions of of fans and then he used
that to launch a chocolate business
that's going to be worth billions of
dollars plus his back catalog is worth a
lot of money plus his sponsorships and
and AD Revenue will make a lot of money
plus any other business he launches will
make a lot of money right so he he just
did the he he is a movie movie
production studio in terms of his
operations but he's like a venture he
more like a venture back startup than he
is like a Creator can you talk so when I
hear about the way that he lives part
I'm definitely inspired but I'm only
inspired because I'm not going to change
the way I do things so much like him
because that's just not my personality
and I don't think that's what I enjoy is
to be that Allin of like you know I'm
more well balanced which means I'm going
to be less successful and I'm okay with
that but there are um you had other guys
there so Joe gbia I don't know what his
intensity levels like I've only spent
three minutes with them and I've read
about them that's about it but then you
also had sad so scad's 32 sad has
businesses he was on our podcast he's
got businesses that no one will talk
about because it's not really that
popular but I imagine he's in the realm
of being a billionaire and then you had
Joe gbia who's multi-billionaire and his
company is one of the biggest and best
in the world
how did did you learn different
perspectives on how to crush it based
off of being around like those three
examples Jimmy Sayad and uh
Joe yeah 100 perc I'll give you a couple
of quick observations so one observation
is uh by the way there was probably like
two or three more people that were like
you know billionaires at this event so
you get to see like a range of like oh
how do people act how do people think
how do people operate and it's like yeah
s's like small team simple business
unsexy not going to be famous don't want
to be famous don't want people knowing
my name I want to be able to walk around
he travels the world with his son um you
know for two weeks out of every month
that's what he wants in his lifestyle
you talk to Mr Beast about kids and he's
like it's a shame people have kids man
they go soft right he's just like he's
just like he's like damn he he literally
like I don't I W put words in his mouth
but the the general feeling is like it
sucks that people start off really
ambitious trying to do big cool cool
awesome [__] and then
like just get tired or they they either
get tired or worn out or disillusioned
or they just shift their focus to family
and like he's just like that's not GNA
be me um and so you have to totally
different perspectives on these things
and you know no judgment there's many
ways to win each person should choose
the game they want to play um but I will
share a couple of observations number
one this is probably just a good
observation for me in general in life
the smartest and most successful people
in that room were the quietest
they were the ones doing the most
listening the least bragging the least
kind of like you know you know word
vomit of Storytelling or trying to
interject themselves oh you did that I
did something similar too let me tell
you about me me me me and uh it was the
people who were the least successful and
the least you know sharp in terms of
like had the most uh wisdom or or
Intelligence on on a topic that were
talking the most
and I'm guilty of that I'm in the talk
the most Camp so I was like damn that's
a real like takeaway for me from this
was watch how those people operate you
want to be them you have to watch how
they operate and you know they
definitely do that the sort of the ratio
of two ear two ears for every one mouth
right like double the amount of
listening as talking if not more and
that was just so obvious to me at this
event they had the Le and it also the
people who were the actually the most
successful had the least kind of like I
would say the whole group was pretty
good good about like not trying to brag
or one-upsmanship you know or try to
like assert themselves
um but the people who the most
successful had had that had that in in
the least quantity which I thought was
very very interesting the second thing I
thought that was that was interesting
was
um uh just back in in there was like
always these the people who were very
very successful in one area more often
than not if I asked them about some
random side quest hobby they were also
like world class at that thing like we
were talking about you know Joe was
super successful airb he's also like you
know extremely fit notless like kind of
fit he's extremely fit uh Jimmy Mr Beast
you know uh the day after our event he's
like oh I'm uh like what are you doing
tomorrow he's like oh I flew I'm flying
in all of he's like I play this one
board game that's super Niche called
Dune he's like and I there's no
tournament for Dune so I created it and
I'm flying in the the French Champion
the British champion the German Champion
like the best players in the world to
come compete with me at this game he's
like I did this last year and I won he's
like I play you know these guys Play
10,000 hours a year whatever 100,000
hours a year or something crazy like I
don't have that time but I like you know
when I do play I binge this thing you
know that's my way of unwinding is to
become world class at this random Niche
strategy board game and like we've heard
these stories about how you know Peter
teal is also a Grandmaster chess
champion or Travis kalanick was ranked
number three in wi 10
we tennis globally right and it's like
yeah jiby literally won the competition
against the other best champions in the
world at this board game and they they
were so bad they're like we got to run
this back he's like great let's run it
back let's do it again this year and
like you know he put up a 20 grand price
there's like no prize pull for this
thing uh because it's like such a niche
game and I thought that's also kind of
interesting which is once you develop
kind of this laser beam that can come
out of your eyes and you hone that laser
beam on your main thing if you ever
shift your focus to something else
you're like homelander and you just can
just burn a laser through whatever that
next thing is because you have practiced
the art of you know Obsession Focus
Excellence you know breaking something
down into its core parts and building it
back up again that was the other thing
we I was like dude how do you describe
yourself are
you like do you just are you an
Entertainer are you like a chocolate guy
now are you a business are you a
businessman because you're in a room
with business people like how do are you
a YouTuber what do you call yourself you
know what he said take a guess what he
said I don't know a business Builder
he's like I'm a data
junkie no way he's like yeah I basically
just studied the algorithm I studied the
platform and I figured out what's going
to work and I decided I'm going to study
this more than anyone studies anything
and he's like then I've basically
figured out what type of content's gonna
work and then through my experimentation
I figured out what's going to work like
when they you know when we put up a
thumbnail for our YouTube channel we put
up one thumbnail and sometimes we're
like you know what I don't know if
that's a good and then we're like screw
it we'll AB test are you YouTube team is
going to hear this I'm going to be
freaking out I think they put up a lot
more than that no no they don't they a
test There's A and B that's it you know
what he does he'll put
up they will test like hundreds of
thumbnails like rap in Rapid succession
during the when they first release a
video they will cycle through hundreds
of thumbnails programmatically to try to
find the winning one during that and
then they're also like well our loyal
fans our hardcore viewers come first
they're going to want to see Jimmy's
face but after that after you know
basically the 24-hour period it's going
to be more fans that are from the
platform just people browsing YouTube
they don't know Jimmy they don't want to
see his face so let's just put this uh
you know this bathtub full of sakks or
whatever the the challenge is let's make
that the thumbnail Jack told me about
that and I go Jack is he doing that
because he's so big or is he so big
because he did that and he said the
second
one he's so big because he did that yes
yeah yeah yeah I'm like he's successful
because of that he doesn't do that now
because he's successful another random
nerdy takeaway I had
um actually I'll just leave it as this
last one so the random nerdy takeaway um
he is making the the biggest he he is
attacking the biggest Tam on YouTube so
like Tam is this idea of total
addressable market and I could think of
a viral idea maybe an idea that's that's
kind of Juicy but like his ideas
are uh like you know year-old in the
Philippines or a 25-year-old in the
United States or a 40-year-old woman in
in the UK would all be interested in his
video why because his his video is a
like it's a video you don't even need
words to explain you could literally
just with the thumbnail or like a
hieroglyphic explain this it's like man
trapped in room 100 days all right I'm
interested what is that right or like
you know um you know two people uh you
know first to to leave the circle loses
it's like okay I get it and a million
dollars first to leave the circle loses
or he'll do a video that's like um
million dollars if this if this like you
know FBI agent can catch me right it's
this like very very simple premises that
appeal to a really really broad amount
of people and I just that was something
I hadn't really appreciated before I
thought he was making kind of like viral
click baity type of stuff what I didn't
factor in was he will only pick ideas
that can literally appeal to like one
billion people and that's just different
than what most people do on the platform
most people don't like our channel for
example the stuff we talk about it's not
meant to do that it's meant to appeal to
a narrow niche of people in a deep way
he plays a different game appeal to the
entire world in a small way what did you
think of hanging out with like guys like
Jack Smith and Val that so that the
first so we had Val or I had one day you
weren't here so I had Val on the Pod Val
is a guy who has like four different
companies with like three or two of them
in the100 million dollar a year range
what did you think of hanging out with a
guy like Val he's cool right everybody
had interesting things to share can I
tell you the low lights because I don't
want to just say all the good things can
I tell you the bad things yeah first uh
the big the worst thing was not getting
to invite everyone so we only invited 20
people this year we invited less people
than last year because last year was
kind of a lot to manage like we had
almost 30 people last year this year we
targeted 15 so we tried to cut it in
half um it ended up being 20 at the end
but uh that was the worst part
because you know it's really really hard
to say no to people or like not invite
people who you're friends with you just
didn't want you know they just you're
trying to create an event where there's
new people there and so therefore you
just can't do it so that was the that
was shitty uh also another thing I hate
hosting these things I know it's good
meaning there's so much value in hosting
this people feel so app a lot of work
it's a lot of work and it's honestly I'm
okay with work it's just socially like I
feel drained you know sometime you say
this about the podcast you're like dude
I feel drained after these and I'm like
dude I could go all
day at the end of the night every one of
these I'm like I am so overs soed out I
am I'm I'm I'm an introvert actually it
turns out you're performing as well and
I want everybody to have a good time and
it's like dude you can't control if
people are having a good time yeah
you're working basically and so it was
socially I felt so uh exhausted socially
exhausted is the right word the last one
or a couple other ones
basketball kind of mediocre it was
pretty sloppy because the overlap of
people people who are you know super
successful and interesting that also are
good pickup basketball players
surprisingly
low also people lie we're like yo do you
play they're like yeah love to they show
up I'm like you don't play do you next
year do fighting do fight camp that so
we agreed to do a fight Camp I talked to
Michael bisbing before Michael bisbing a
UFC guy and YouTuber he would be
interesting because if he would everyone
would want to meet Jimmy or joia Michael
bising would be cool I bet I mean you
know some UFC guys have listened to us
and dm'd us that would be fun I want
this is what I want to do I want to take
any of like the kind of the Hobbies uh
and then mix basically integrate them so
right rather than like work life balance
where it's like there's the things I
like to do and then there's work and
then they're separate they're always
trading off time against each other no
no integrate them and so take something
I love to do which would be like you
know like boxing or or sparring in some
way or basketball and integrate it with
like you know a networking event
basically and you lost you lost so last
year last year was crazy because this is
when I saw that Jimmy was insane we were
all just hanging out this B basketball
court and he like didn't even make an
ordeal of it he was goes hey Sean if you
can make this half court shot I'll give
you $10,000 and he didn't even say like
if you don't make it I get this or you
only have three shots to make it like
there was no I was like what the [__]
Jimmy why would you make this bet and he
was just insane and he did it and you
did it in like number five or three or
something and he gave you 10 grand
and I heard this year you lost 10 grand
doing the same thing someone another low
light I lost the half court shot this
year I lost 10 grand to Joe and it's one
thing to lose $10,000 it's another thing
to lose
$10,000 to a multi-billionaire because I
was like oh damn this is uh this is a
has a little extra kick to it so yeah
you paid for 15 minutes 15 minutes fly
time on his
jet
exactly exactly um and actually we
because we lost the game we had to go
and do the like ice Plunge in the like
freezing cold lake thing um so that was
also you know part of the penalty of of
losing the final championship game so
that kind of sucked um yeah so those
were some of the some of the low lights
someone who went mentioned to me they
didn't say that you guys discussed this
but I assumed because he kept bringing
it up about prime um and apparent so
this is pretty mind so the Mr Beast
stuff is mindboggling that he has a
chocolate company that makes hundreds of
millions of dollars I looked up Prime so
Prime was started by Logan Paul and KSI
publicly they said that the business in
the second year business did $1.2
billion in revenue and I imagine that
Prime must have come up in your
conversations and I someone said that
the two guys who founded it alongside
Logan and KSI were like young kids
almost like they imply like they were
nobody's like they had no business in
getting into this industry and it has
just crushed it and I guess my mind is
like a billion dollars in sales that's
worth if your Prime that's worth like a
really high multiple because of how fast
it's growing that's worth billions of
dollars so you basically have created
billions and billions of dollars in
value off of a Creator it's mindboggling
did you learn anything interesting about
prime yeah so I I think some of that's
accurate and some of it's not so they
did do over a billion dollars by 1.3 1.5
billion and what's kind of like its
first full year you know it launched in
2022 so the 202 three numbers are the
First full year of of you know full
calendar year of business so that's
that's Bonkers right obviously that's
Bonkers no what what business does over
a billion dollars in Revenue in its
first year that's be crazy um they're
not kids so I think they're in their 20s
but they're not kids they are also not
like never done this before remember we
talked about those like status signals
of like uh the the green flags of when
you're young like video game player um
hacker of of popular thing another one
you know running your own Minecraft
server that's another one um one other
one is sneaker flipper so these guys
were sneaker flippers that's how they
kind of like that was their Road into
business was selling you know sneakers
then they created this uh kind of like
they did a couple things but then they
they ended up creating something called
Alani new which I don't know if you
heard about this but it's like kind of
this like Posh drink that like um it was
started with this Instagram Creator
she's not anywhere near the level of
like a Logan Paul or whatever U but they
started this thing they've done
Partnerships with Kim Kardashian and
others like they made Kim Aid like the
Kim Kardashian flavor thing Alani knew
they did before Prime like an energy
drink and a pre-workout supplement right
yeah but it's like for women and it's
like high-end it's like the you know
Equinox or whatever got it and it's uh
Alani new does over hundred million
dollars of profit per year so it's a
that itself is a almost billion dollar
revenue revenue generating things that's
that is that itself is probably a
multi-billion dollar company that they
built before Prime so these guys did
that they have this this hold code
called Congo Brands they don't want
people to know about them you go to
LinkedIn great picture you go to Congo
Brands not much story if anybody asks
who owns Prime they say Logan Paul and
KSI in reality these guys own 60% of
that company right Logan and KSI own you
know the sort of like 30 to 40% of that
company and so um that brand Prime is
going to be my guess is that that that
ends up being like a 20 billion dollar
brand it's
crazy you know that is gonna make Logan
Paul a multi-billionaire off of off of
uh Prime so you know Celsius you know
that energy drink yeah Celsius just sold
eight% to Pepsi for 550 million so
Celsius is valued at six
billion Prime is bigger than Celsius
it's going to be bigger than Celsius or
it already is bigger than Celsius and so
what an insane story and that guy Trey
uh you know Mr Beast Jimmy he was like I
call him like he's like I call that guy
every day he's like that guy is so
helpful to me with Feasta bbls he's like
I'm calling that guy all the time he is
so smart he's like he is so smart so
much smarter than everybody else in this
space it's insane and he's like I I am
just getting so much learning from that
guy and he's like that's why I like to
meet people that I can learn from
because I've seen how how much fat you
know he's like same thing for me he's
like if I wanted to if you took my
channel away I could rebuild right back
to where I am in three years he's like
that's how Trey is with
cpg and he's like I'm just trying to
find who that person is for all the
different fields he's like I want to
meet them yeah what's crazy is if you
Google Trey like his name like you
barely get anything there's no
interviews I I try I've tried hard to
find you know some him on YouTube or an
interview with him nothing that's insane
um last question all right so you did
this thing you know what we call that
lasagna I know it tell them why tell
them why we call this lasagna Sam what
is it you move in silent
moving silence like lasagna um all right
so you did this thing at worst it was
fun at best it was life-changing if it
is lifechanging how are you going to
change laser focus my friend uh in fact
during the thing uh you should have just
listened to me four years ago should
have listened to you then but the thing
is you don't really have the same level
of inspiration and motivation that Mr
Beast this is true and I'm not nearly as
successful as them if I had a few if I
had few zeros behind uh my bank account
or uh my my Instagram account maybe you
would have listened but it just it just
sucks you couldn't have listen to them
it's laser focus on content specifically
because uh you know one realization you
got to know who you are and you got to
know what you're into uh for me I think
I'm probably like a B+ entrepreneur but
I think I could be A+ in the content
game I think I it would be impossible
really for me to be A+ as an
entrepreneur I don't think I'm it's not
where I'm naturally as talented uh plus
I don't enjoy it enough to go that hard
as hard as you would want to to be at
that top tier but I do feel that way
about making content so that's what I'm
going to do I'm gonna try to build the
largest content brand or audience around
entrepreneurship so around people who
who are into the same [__] we're into
right MFM has been awesome and it's like
the it's kind of shown that that can be
true but uh it's never been something
I'm laser focused on and I also don't
think podcast is the right vehicle to do
that so I'm going to do it off off of
podcasting because podcasting is not
viral which is like what you what you
want is to be able to spread your gospel
to as many people as possible the
problem with podcasting is podcasting is
like bottom of funnel it's like it's
like where people you know form a deep
relationship it's not where they meet
you do you get Envy so like when I
thought about I've thought about that as
well um I'm not into content creation as
much as you so that's not going to be
the path for me but I have used it as um
you know like a miniat
Logan Paul Prime thing very very very
Min miniature compared to them um do you
think that so for entrepreneurship that
sort of means that you're going to be a
B2B like uh you know sha to you're going
to sell something that businesses might
buy or something that like we'll call it
like the prosumer so like not like a
drink but maybe someone who buys
something for their job um do you think
that there's as many opportunities in
that space as there is creating a drink
or a makeup kit or or uh whatever other
consumer roles and also I'm not even
worried about that like that will exist
and uh it'll be what it'll be doesn't
really matter uh but yeah it does like
you know I don't think Tim Ferris when
he started you know four hour work week
or even his podcast would have been like
yeah and then what I'm gonna do is
invest in Uber and make a hundred
million like that's what happened but
it's not what you would have predicted
but of course how does he get into that
deal because he's Tim Ferris that's what
who people want to rope into things and
so you know getting into Shopify and and
Uber early on is how you made all the
money um you couldn't really connect
those dots at the beginning right it's
only something that later after the fact
you could see how that all connected
together and are you prepared to be a
38-year-old YouTuber hanging out with a
bunch of 22 year olds all the time while
you're wearing I didn't say I was to do
I
didn't do
YouTube Noah my good friend Noah Kagan
he uh you know he runs a really
successful business that's worth
hundreds of millions dollar so he's
successful but he um he has like a
YouTube channel and I always make fun of
him like dude you're a 42 Old YouTuber
you [__] dork like you're hanging out
with all 22 year olds who like yoyo
still like what do you like grow up
Peter Pan uh and so that's what I'll be
making fun of you about uh so you could
go and like do all those dude we had you
and I had to do a photo shoot recently
because MFM they wanted to upload the
title or the the picture and in that
photo shoot we had to stand there and do
like 10 emotions they're like all right
act yeah thumbnail faces act like you're
someone just said something stupid and
you think they're full of it and like
inevitably every picture is just this
like you're you're
shocked and like we had to do these
things first of all I hated that I hated
that it was horrible dude there was one
where you had your head like this like
you're going to smack someone yeah they
were like you're angry and then I did a
[__] slap uh hand thing I was like was
that I was like what are you doing yeah
and and then they had to like I just had
to hold up five four three so they could
like use my hands for different numbers
I hated that I hated doing that um so
we're going to be seeing that but I
can't like that's just not my DNA but
that um that's gonna be you now
congratulations it's hard for me to be a
little [__] but I hope you enjoy it
yeah no it was just like you know like
you know a lot of the YouTubers um and
this is a good thing they're they're
actors they're they're performers
they're entertainers we sort of started
this just like hang out when we go to
places and people are like oh my gosh I
need your autograph oh can take a
picture I'll be like and this is Sam and
I'll introduce you too okay so don't
worry well it was just well you have a
little bit more of that acting DNA but
they they like you like performing a
little bit but they um these guys are
like hard they're they're you I mean
YouTubers are actors and so it's it's
you say YouTube I didn't say I'm going
do YouTube necessarily I know you didn't
say that but I'm I'm still going to make
fun of you for doing that don't let
reality get in the way of what I'm going
to mock you for uh can I tell you okay
so one of the things we did at this Camp
by the way is I'm not going to tell you
what was in it but I'll tell you what we
did so last year I was too afraid to
like structure it meaning last year I
was like yeah we're just gonna hang it's
GNA be cool it's G to be casual it's
gonna be great it's gonna be awesome
just hanging no problem just super cool
because I was like I don't want to be
the second grade teacher be like all
right everybody sit down you know give
me your sh like your bunny ears and like
let's dude in reality you need that you
need that we needed that and we needed
that and and one of the best things last
year was when somebody finally impromptu
was like Hey so do you guys want to do
like some intros or like an icebreaker
like who who are you guys and what what
do you do can we learn something from
each other so this year I arranged it
where I was like all right we're gonna
do these things called tiny talks that I
was like at night we're gonna have
people do kind of like a flash you know
five to 10 minute talk on their thing
because everybody in this room is world
class at something otherwise you
wouldn't be in this room so tell us what
your world class at and how you do it so
that we can kind of learn from it so it
was like you know Mr Beast does his
YouTube Master Class he's like here
here's my channel here's the analytics
he's like you know just logs in he's
screen sharing he's like so here's how
we think about this here's what I did
here's what worked here's what didn't
work here's this trick we do on our
thumbnails that makes this work better I
mean like you couldn't pay for this
right so he did that Joe gbia did one on
his first startup before Airbnb and kind
of like the lessons he learned there
read read the title and only give a one
sentence summary of uh the takeaway that
you had uh how I went from zero to 1.3
billion in real estate in 10 years um
The One sented summary is this guy has
an unfair advantage that lets him play
the game differently and I should just
give him my money to invest and that's
what I'm doing okay so like uh yeah
unfair advantages do exist and when you
have them just part you know press push
your push your chips into the table uh
all right next one why I bought 23 gas
stations and was it a good idea uh so
last year at the camp somebody shared
about why how they owned a you know 10
gas stations or something so one of the
guys went and bought 23 gas stations
after that and um funny story and
actually it probably was a good idea for
him because you know he had sold his
business and he needed something that
would give him a lot of depreciation in
year one a lot of bonus depreciation and
gas stations do do that so in that sense
it was a smart move but now he holds all
these assets that like he's going to
have to figure out if they were the
right thing on in the long term I think
there's different thing another guy did
a presentation on why Venture Capital
mostly sucks and why people play the
game totally wrong and he is a VC um so
I thought that was a great talk at the
end of it he did this thing called the
Mount Rushmore of death that I thought
was interesting he's like we were like
dude how did you even think of investing
in this one company that that took off
it sold for like three billion dollar
and he goes
well he's like I first was taking like a
thousand meetings a year like most VCS
do and they're just like so inundated
with data that they actually like lose
the way to think like so then I step
back and I was like okay I'm not going
to do just like constant inbound
meetings just worried about missing the
next big thing instead I'm gonna figure
out where would the next big thing live
and I'm GNA go find it so he did this
thing called the Mount Rushmore of death
which is like these four things cause
death more than anything else combined
right like these make up 80% of all the
reasons for death uh petera calls these
The Four Horsemen but the he did this
guy did Mount Rushmore and it's like
heart disease
diabetes cancer and and um dementia and
yeah like dementia Alzheimer so like
neuro neuro cognitive um degeneration
and he's like so then I just went and
looked for what's the best company uh in
biotech that attacks one of those four
in a way that I think is plausible to to
work and then he ended up finding a big
winner in that space I thought that was
kind of interesting um another guy he
goes my talks about the 3DS of B of
buying businesses death divorce and
distressed he's like you know the the
best opportunities come if you can buy a
business from somebody who died and the
kids don't want to inherit the business
from somebody who's going through a
divorce and they have to you know sell
their business or distressed you know
somebody took on too much risk and you
can basically go buy it for less than
the intrinsic value of the business and
so one guy there he had bought a
business he was looking at buying this
business he would have had to pay like
you know 1520 million for it um on top
of the inventory that they had and
instead he ended up own now he owns the
business for the cost of the inventory
that they own like he's like literally
like I just paid for the inventory and I
now own the whole business and he's like
you know and that was one of my supplier
so it cut my cogs in half so it's just
like these great you know what do what
does a great deal look like and you
really start to learn what does a great
deal look like so those talks I thought
were badass all right let's wrap up and
let me make one suggestion don't turn
this into a business this is perfect as
it is don't [__] this a business Camp
MFM this is awesome of course not this
is perfect don't [__] this up number two
do it again and number three keep it at
whatever size 20 I I would be bad at
picking because I would want everyone to
come that is so stressful but hopefully
you don't ruin this because this is
definitely a gem um I'm when we made the
list of people we would want to come the
list was
142 so you had to go from 142 to
inviting
15 that was terrible I was I had I'm I
don't regret my decision I you know I I
had to put family time in but I had
immense amount of after all of that you
didn't regret your decision no I don't
regret it at I don't regret it but but I
I I I have massive fomo I wish I was in
a position that it would have been that
I could have made it but uh I I'm I had
huge amount of fomos because Ramone and
Jack were giving me updates and Val and
Ben and Nick and I would just text
people like how's it going is it fun and
they would send me pictures so I sort of
got like 1% of you know ongoing updates
it sounded awesome everybody at the
thing was just they were just calling it
Sean's bachelor party they're like I'm
so happy to be at Sea's bachelor party
which is hilarious because I didn't have
a bachelor party but if I did this is
exactly what I would have wanted to do
it's basically group of guys who are all
a lot of fun uh tons of jokes play
basketball play poker talk business
that's like the ideal bachelor party so
I think maybe we should just rebranded
to that my annual bachelor party well no
keep it Camp FFM so I by default always
get an invite
no dude you blew us off this
year you know how it is you would have
done the same thing um and if it's
people were like where's Sam and I was
like oh you know he just had a baby
they're like wasn't that like three
months ago and I was like yeah and
they're like then it was two and a half
months ago it was two and a half months
ago and I made the commitment that the
first three I'm I'm at home um I got to
do it I got to do laser focus on that
baby I like it I appreciate that we you
know I was I actually got a I was
getting um
I was laying with her and I was like
shirtless and she was just in her diaper
and I was changing her diaper and she
[__] all over me somehow as I was
getting a text from uh like Ramone being
like yeah dude now we're lifting weights
and doing all this stuff I was like oh
cool like uh let me wipe this poop off
of me real quick because she just the
poop just ran down my belly uh any tips
how to get diarrhea out
of dude is there a tiny talk about that
she literally puked on my face this week
cuz I was like holding her at my
shoulder and she threw up and I got
puked all over my face and I was like
reading these texts and like seeing Nick
puber do like a dexa scan and Joe G jump
in a lake and I'm like oh that's yeah we
had he has a dexa in his gym and we put
Nick on it and then we played a game
where everybody had to guess his body
fat percentage and then I was like yeah
this would get everybody canceled
nowadays this is like you know fat
shaming I pretty sure this is the
definition of f shaming but uh but he
loved it it was great yeah that's that's
baller I definitely uh wish I could have
been there um all right that was a good
episode that was a good recap all
[Music]
right